con los cementerios desbordados este
martes brasil rompió el trágico récord
de muertes diarias por kobe 19 con 4 mil
195 fallecimientos sumando cerca de 337
mil decesos y más de 13 millones de
contagios
sao paulo el estado más desarrollado
registró un nuevo máximo con mil 389
muertes el epicentro de la pandemia en
el mundo afronta la peor fase de la
enfermedad agravada por las laxas
medidas para contener los contagios del
presidente de ultraderecha jair
bolsonaro miras las nuevas variantes del
patógeno están abrumando los hospitales
con el sistema de salud brasileño al
borde del colapso y donde la campaña de
vacunación de sus 212 millones de
habitantes avanza a un ritmo lento
apenas el 10 por ciento de la población
ha recibido la primera dosis más al sur
en argentina las autoridades sanitarias
reportaron la cifra más alta de
contagios desde el inicio de la pandemia
20 mil 870 casos positivos en 24 horas
para un total de 2,4 millones de
contagios y más de 56 mil 600 decesos en
la última semana el acelerado ritmo de
los contagios ha puesto en alerta al
país por lo que el gobierno del
presidente alberto fernández enfermó de
kobe 19 impuso
restricciones de cara a la segunda ola
del coronavirus tras un periodo
vacacional de semana santa en el que la
actividad turístico pero con aparente
normalidad ahora estamos todos muy
asustados la gente no se cuida en un
salvar o hijos al en los bares canasta
cualquier horas hay boliches así que no
sé cómo está todo está bastante mal toda
la gente tiene mucho miedo y en cuba por
octavo día consecutivo notificó más de
mil nuevos contagios de coronavirus para
un total acumulado de 81 1640 y poco más
de 400 decesos desde el inicio de la
pandemia lo llamativo es que al 1 de
enero de 2021 cubas apenas registraba de
otri mil casos y se preciaba de ser un
modelo de control pero la reapertura del
aeropuerto en diciembre y la baja
percepción de riesgo ha elevado
exponencialmente los contagios el
gobierno de la isla impondrá drásticas
medidas para frenar la propagación del
virus